un rond de feu sans vie une scène sans
magie lakovic 19 a eu raison des séjours
à la base de plein air jean jeunes tous
se préparait en mars pour l'été et pour
l'automne et pour l'hiver donc pour nous
ça complètement arrêter tous nos revenus
couverts depuis 75 ans le 15 juin se
déploie sur 120 acres de terrain un
grand site comme ici avec sept bâtiments
juste à payer les frais fixes et au
moins 100 mille dollars pour se sortir
la tête de l'eau cet été l'organisme
loue ses infrastructures tout en
respectant les normes sanitaires
stefanko canaux d'anima tour a plus de
chances entreprises privées elle loue
ses installations pour fonctionner mais
l'avenir est sombre pour ce camp qui
attire une clientèle locale et
internationale
c'est comme un 11 septembre mais en pire
il va faire que la confiance revienne
on ne parlera la rentrée scolaire au
moment des réservations de toute la
prochaine année scolaire des voyages
scolaires que de d'éventuels deuxième
drug une aide financière est demandée
pour survivre à la disette les camps de
vacances sont en danger
il faut bien comprendre sans si le
gouvernement n'a pas un rôle d' aide
mais direct pas d aide au développement
n'est pas un bon type de subvention
parce qu'on n'aura jamais les moyens de
leurs rangs
moursi selon l'association des camps du
québec sept établissements sur 10 sont
menacés de fermeture à moyen terme
on a déjà évoqué un chiffre de 22
millions avec le gouvernement pour venir
en soutien souple s'assurer de se rendre
à l'été prochain pour préserver les
milieux naturels et les rendre
accessibles à tous mais surtout pour les
enfants
ça fait partie du patrimoine et de
l'héritage qu'on laisse de génération en
génération aux gens dit la directrice
espère que la légende du camp gens
jeunes celle de tiges ans pourra être
racontée encore longtemps
les durées fait pareil quand les
gendarmes tout cas où le cas ici marie
josée paquet comme radio-canada vendée